algunos mini bloques rusos han asegurado
de que estos avances de las fuerzas
ucranianas en los alrededores de bakú
hacen parte de la llamada o esperada
contra ofensiva sin embargo esto se
niega desde kiev días atrás el
presidente
aseguraba que esta contraofensiva
tendría que esperar un tiempo más
mientras llegaban nuevas armas para
fortalecer a esas brigadas que están
destinadas a esta contra ofensiva lo que
sí muestra estos avances ucranianos
especialmente al norte de y al sur de
esta población Es que la dinámica ha
venido cambiando en los últimos días el
Ministerio de defensa del Reino Unido
que monitorea la guerra hablaba de un
kilómetro cuadrado al sur de bakmut que
estaría ahora en control de las tropas
ucranianas después de que tropas rusas
se retiraran de allí lo que muestra
también esa división que hay en las
tropas de Moscú como ya lo venía
anunciando desde hace días el fundador
de las tropas o de las fuerzas
que aseguraba que no solamente algunas
fuerzas rusas se retiraban sino que
estaban dejando en bala la posición a
las fuerzas wagners que estaban luchando
en el centro de la ciudad esto también
llega en un momento en el que ambas
fuerzas se atacan entre ellas ayer la
ciudad ocupada de Luján fue atacada
fuertemente aseguran estas fuerzas
ocupantes que dos fábricas que no
estaban siendo utilizadas fueron
atacadas pero una gran humareda y esta
madrugada Rusia volvió a lanzar ataques
contra Ucrania estos fueron en kievf
nicoláis y en la región de criminiches
que donde dos fábricas serían atacadas
una gran humanidad 21 personas quedaron
heridas y también hoy en una gran
noticia para Ucrania Alemania anunció la
primera o la mayor gran ayuda que ha
dado desde el comienzo de la guerra
serían 2700 millones que ría tanto en
tanques como en vehículos blindados como
en defensa aérea lo que vendría a
reforzar esa ayuda dada también por
Estados Unidos y otros países de la
Unión Europea en los últimos días